[Music]
in a world full of senseless violence
political strife and corporate greed
three movies about those things also
exist the purge trilogy get ready for
purge night a new American holiday where
all crimes are legal but everyone goes
straight for murderer in an annual
free-for-all that you either treat like
Halloween for psychopaths mass or an
excuse to throw a really boring dinner
party
prepare for three zombie movies if the
zombies were just regular folks who need
therapy in three plots where a group of
people don't take the purse seriously
enough where's later than I thought you
know we don't have a whole lot of time
before commencement Shane I'll secure a
safe house in full security detail no
I'm staying then get kidnapped by an old
white murder called and are rescued by a
POC X monkey da
come with us they're like get out with
two of the same actors but infinitely
less subtlety write out the first purge
movie with Ethan Hawke and Cersei
Lannister in a low-budget home invasion
movie let's have shots of dimly lit
hallways and have shots of people doing
PvP emotes at security cameras then up
the ante with discount Jon Bernthal in
purge anarchy and election year cranking
the tension of the first one down in two
generic gun driven action movies with
just enough lashes of perjury to make
you say I hope they really embrace the
concept in the next one do you like your
social commentary veiled in metaphor too
bad because these movies have a message
as subtle as the giant blood letters on
the Lincoln Memorial that aren't afraid
to deal with class who dies tonight the
poor immigrants drugging me on job seven
years ago when I first came in from
Mexico insurance companies they just
raised a premium on my purge coverage by
thousands capitalism guns we worship at
the altar of Smith & Wesson insurance
companies capitalism and guns
governmental ID white supremacists
Russians pretending to be Americans
we love you America a shot of Paul Ryan
with a space blurred out and a leader
named Donald T it's way too on-the-nose
if the government really wanted to kill
poor people they just make health care
housing in the legal system unaffordable
so settle in for a franchise with
amazing potential that could be a little
more creative in its execution instead
of just creative in its executions
in films that make you reconsider the
value of unleashing your violent
impulses killing doesn't help anything
by showing the scene after scene of
awesome stylized violence oh yeah tell
me watch people die oh yeah whoa a
guillotine sit
we are not hypocrites yeah you kinda are
starring after sunset but before sunrise
rushmore jose cancer see the punisher
thing that Saracen can't catch a break
Bernie would have purged Spring Breakers
car trouble cars dead our steering's
calling me the power steering's gone
there is no car and jump-scares
fortnight Battle Royale vertical video
in the White House
this truly is a dark future incredible
Asst can you rock with the cook is
smelling Mangal scree on squirrels in my
pants
wow that vegan pizza wasn't too bad